[Música]
bienvenidos de nuevo directo con 26 el
programa especial de france 24 para
debatir lo que ocurre en la cumbre
climática de la onu en glasgow faltan
pocas horas de negociación entre los
líderes en este encuentro que finaliza
mañana aun quedan sobre la mesa algunos
anuncios importantes en cuanto a
reducción de producción de petróleo y
gas pero el tema del día era ciudades
regiones y entornos construidos
ampliamos desde glasgow con nuestra
enviada especial marina colorada
y valentina y es que las ciudades son
cruciales para frenar el cambio
climático y es importantísimo que éstas
se adapten a un planeta cambiante porque
se calcula que en 2050 el 68 por ciento
de la población mundial vivirá en zonas
urbanas un porcentaje que en américa
latina' sube hasta el 86 por ciento
precisamente para hablar de este crucial
papel de las ciudades me acompaña
sebastián navarro él es el enviado
global de la ruta santiago glasgow y
secretario general de cdc 35 que es la
coalición de ciudades capitales de las
américas frente al cambio climático
bienvenido a france 24 de nuevo
sebastián a los perdones ali khan el
alcalde de londres dijo que las ciudades
son las que hacen y los países son los
que retrasan explícanos qué quiere decir
esto en primer lugar marina quiero
agradecer a todos los corresponsales de
france 24 en glasgow en nombre de la
alcaldesa heras y hustler de santiago de
chile y de la líder de glasgow susan
aiken porque es el compromiso que
france24 ha tenido para comunicar a la
ciudadanía la emergencia que vive el
planeta
en cuanto a las declaraciones alcalde de
londres
estamos completamente seguros que
y los países las naciones van a ser
condenados por la ciudadanía
para ser condenado cuando dices
condenados por la ciudad global
sin ninguna duda hoy están obstruyendo
las negociaciones están obstruyendo en
la posibilidad de que el mundo llegue a
un acuerdo a un acuerdo posible y creo
que fue muy claro alcalde de londres en
expresar seguramente que las naciones
van a tener que integrar a los gobiernos
en unas salidas en las negociaciones en
un futuro esto lo vamos a ver en breve y
precisamente acerca de esas acciones que
están tomando los gobiernos
subnacionales de ciudades de regiones
cuáles son algunos anuncios qué
destacarías bueno nosotros a mí como
enviado legal me ha tocado traer
anuncios muy concretos a la cob 26 me
prometí que era importante tener
anuncios muy muy concretos en glasgow y
158 ciudades tenemos en sitios restos
eran más de mil ciudades con compromiso
de neutralidad carbono entre 2030 y 2050
nosotros hemos traído al único país del
planeta con 158 alcaldes ese alcalde que
firmaron sus compromisos neutralidad de
carbono en la república desde la
república dominicana en la iniciativa
alcaldes por el clima hemos anunciado el
primer fondo climático es súper nacional
de 750 millones de con el green
clementson liderado por el r20 pegasus
capital y un consorcio de instituciones
que han logrado empezar a
generar nuevos mecanismos de
financiamiento para una arquitectura
financiera que ya no tiene respuestas
para para un mundo que necesita ir más
aceleradamente hacia asia la
infraestructura de descarbonización y
este texto que se está negociando en
estas últimas horas del cob 26 cuando
afecta lo que se decida aquí a las
políticas que se llevan a cabo todos los
días del año desde los gobiernos locales
y desde los gobiernos regionales yo creo
que hay una desconexión de los gobiernos
nacionales con
con el botón botón up con la parte de
abajo hacia arriba que está surgiendo y
sin ninguna duda va a ser al revés que
las políticas y las regulaciones de
gobiernos locales van a terminar
influenciando en las naciones en las
regulaciones nacionales y ahí vemos una
oportunidad una oportunidad para que se
pueda cumplir con el acuerdo de parís
desde desde la base desde la ciudadanía
desde los gobiernos locales no tengo
duda que va a ser así y que en un año
estaremos viendo seguramente un nuevo
escenario de negociaciones donde si no
se incluye a los gobiernos subnacionales
tendremos problemas en un futuro y en
breve tendremos a la naturaleza cortando
el crédito del sistema así que aunque
mañana o pasado mañana cuando haya un
acuerdo las conclusiones no sean tan
positivas como esperábamos hay esperanza
si la ciudanía tiene que saber qué
tiene que acudir en breve estaremos
viendo a naciones en las cortes supremas
ciudadanías demandando a los gobiernos
nacionales por incumplimiento ya lo
hemos visto en el caso de europa y lo va
a empezar a pasar con los países de
américa latina y cada país tiene que
hacerse cargo y responsable de la
reducción de sus emisiones tiene que
hacerse cargo de ir al 30 por ciento de
protección del planeta para 2030 porque
es la única manera de no podemos seguir
esperando echándole la culpa a los otros
y decirles que si no nos dan los
recursos entonces nos vamos no vamos a
no vamos a cumplir con el acuerdo de
parís llegó el mundo que cada uno cumpla
la parte que tiene que cumplir pues
claramente estás cumpliendo tu parte a
quien negociando y luchando por esos
derechos climáticos desde abajo hacia
arriba y nosotros como medio de
comunicación seguiremos haciendo nuestra
parte desde glasgow marina muchas
gracias por esta ampliación y a ustedes
por su sintonía continúen con nosotros
que hay más en france 24
[Música]